[Music]
different kind of action movie is
opening on Friday now I'm talking about
the final Fifty Shades film Fifty Shades
freed cameras back with us from Paris at
a very romantic spot hey guys yeah I'm
hanging out right in front of Palais
Garnier a more than 150 year old opera
house right here in the heart of Paris
and backdrop in the Fifty Shades freed
movie and stars Dakota Johnson and Jamie
Dornan very happy to be back in Paris
welcome back to this beautiful beautiful
venue how tough is it to say goodbye to
this character it doesn't feel tough it
feels it feels pretty great yes sir the
subject matter is is obviously a bit
intense over the course of the three
films that never got easier luckily
Jamie and I were so comfortable with
each other and it felt safe and
protected but it's still an environment
that's scary
a wild four and a half year ride that
culminates with a gray wedding and
plenty of steamy red moon scenes Jamie
says he's ready now to focus on roles
which are less about his six-pack if you
also this is us see what's up of course
you know the Kevins character and the
mommy or whatever he's always like
they're always like you just take your
shirt off
in Fifty Shades freed Jamie also unveils
something for the first time his singing
voice which is featured on the
soundtrack
[Music]
you could be in a boy band if you wanted
to wish I think he hey
[Music]
yup Jamie was in a short-lived UK band
sons of Jim but one thing he refuses to
do again give Dakota an on-set souvenir
when we did the first movie I got out of
something framed from the Red Room which
seemed like a good idea at the time
and then her reaction proved that it
maybe it wasn't a very good idea did you
keep it by any chance in my garage at
least it's still in your possession put
it in my house it's just maybe one day
but also probably not did you take
another souvenir or something that you
could remember these films by or just my
emotional trauma which you will have
hold on to very tightly fifty Shades
freed opens Friday February 9th and now
I gotta go I got a lot more sights to
see and food to eat in Paris before I
come home
[Music]